[Music]
[Applause]
uh he's paul feinbaum espn radio host
and he hosts uh
a show called the paul fine bomb show
which is convenient because he's paul
feinbaum the voice
of the sec paul thanks for joining us
what would you do if you're ohio state
this weekend
i would call michael buble for advice um
i would hope that right now dan and you
i know you have a lot better sources in
the big ten than i do that
the big ten athletic directors are
currently meeting and and find a
find a game for them i think finding a
game and i heard you mentioned that a
minute ago is better than just saying
okay
you don't have to play this weekend but
you're in the big ten championship game
anyway
it really isn't that complicated i don't
think this is you know they're
they're hanging on uh you know marbury
versus madison as case law from 203
years ago i mean they just
they just they've made up everything
they've done so far so why not make up
another
week of worth of rules but also i i saw
where on social media and some people
have suggested uh ohio state and texas a
m and i thought well if i'm ohio state
why am i
giving texas a m a chance to maybe
leapfrog
us if they would happen to beat us ohio
state's already in the final four
texas a m is going to be on the outside
looking in
yeah i i mean other than the fact that
we all yearn for a quality football game
this weekend which
uh we are not in the in over we're not
overly uh
going to be uh filled with that in terms
of voracious appetites uh there there
really isn't a reason it's just for fun
um you know it's a play-in game but but
you're absolutely right
uh ohio state will probably be in the
playoffs as long as they have
a game next weekend and they'll either
play northwestern or wisconsin or
or someone uh and at six
and 0 they will pass mustard i mean if
the committee
didn't think they were worthy they would
they wouldn't be number four
and that's where they are right now yeah
how do you see this playing out
i i think we'll have a resolution today
um no as far as the
the uh the playoffs so your four teams
do you think will be
who yeah uh i'm
i'm still thinking of michael buble and
when i saw that steve kornacki was on
before me i'm kind of wanted to go run
so uh here's the deal i'd say it's
alabama
i think i think clemson will be notre
dame so clemson gets in there
i think notre dame will still get in
there and it will be ohio state just
just like we ordered it before the
season can florida beat alabama
i i think it would take an extraordinary
uh
set of circumstances uh and and i don't
see that happening
uh right now dan alabama looks
unbeatable to me
uh i mean they are they are so potent on
offense and the biggest
change is on defense uh after the ole
miss game
two months ago uh they were ready to
fire the the defensive coordinator it
looked like saban was too
and they have really shored up and
gotten extremely stingy
and on top of that it's just an
embarrassment of of riches on the
offensive side
alabama has three guys that you could
you can make a compelling case to win
the heisman trophy
uh in devonta smith the wide receiver
nij
harris who doesn't uh who might as well
be in missing persons right now
in the witness protection program you
don't really hear about him at all and
he's one
he may be the best running back in the
country and obviously mac jones
who uh is a co-favorite with kyle trash
to win the whole thing
you start to look at this alabama team
and and when was the evolution
of the offensive side of things for nick
saban because he used to they run the
football and play great defense
but then it felt like hey he looked
around and said
i kind of have to if i'm i'm going to
get these skilled position players and
they all want to go to the nfl and
i'm going to compete with some of these
other uh outliers in the sec or
playing great offense was there a moment
where it changed for nick saban in his
philosophy
yeah it it came really around 2013
2014 nick saban thought he could
influence the
the college football rules committee and
slowed the slow the game down
uh the hurry up was was killing him his
defenses were not prepared for it
and you know he lost a national
championship uh that year on the famous
kick six play
and he decided uh you know what i'm i
don't think i can beat this so i'm going
to join and he hired lane kiffin
uh there is no getting around like lane
kiffin
was the reason alabama entered the
modern era in offense
and kiffin changed it he he helped him
recruiting immensely uh kiffin played a
huge role in
into a tonga viloa coming to alabama and
a number of other players
and then you know kiffin from there uh
it you know sark came in
uh brian dabal by the way was it was was
in between
and he was not particularly uh liked at
alabama although he's now
quite quite well respected in the the
nfl and then sark came back and just
you know finished the job that lane
kiffin started
we're talking to paul feinbaum from the
mothership host of the paul feinbaum
show the voice of the sec i know that
and i i was told this by a source
because i
said why don't we expand the playoffs
this year given everything that's
happened
athletic departments have been decimated
now i get eight schools
in there um i get you know maybe five or
six teams that
are at least playing important games and
maybe getting a chance to get in there
but if why would the sec not be in favor
of this because i was told that and i
thought the sec could get
half of the eight teams in there paul
uh it's true but you know the the men
who run these uh college football power
five conferences dan
please i hope you're sitting down i know
you are they're traditionalists and they
do not like to change
uh i mean i think we're pretty lucky we
have four teams right now the way these
guys
operate things and and you're right
about the sec but
the sec still has a legitimate shot at
getting two in
they have three contending uh they have
one automatic
and you know they're they all see i mean
we watched last
august as you know the five families of
college football
uh the dons could not agree on anything
you had the three conferences wanting to
play you had the two that didn't
and and that is the dysfunctionality of
college football the simple things don't
ever happen and by the way
this was definitely the year to do it
and you know i will you could direct a
question to
to my bosses at the mothership they they
they do have a say
uh in in this altogether but in the end
then
uh it should have happened although i
will say the the opposite
the underbelly of it is i'm not sure how
well it would have worked because i
still think the next three to four weeks
is going to be a challenge to get these
games in
uh especially with the game the
semi-final game slated for the rose ball
i mean
right now can you go out of your house
in in california
yeah you might have to relocate to
arizona the fiesta bowl would be hosting
the rose bowl as well
would you rather have nick saban on the
show or jim harbaugh
jim harbaugh uh and and and i say that
only because i've
you know i've done saban i mean there's
there's uh
you you've interviewed nick saban i mean
and he's the greatest coach of all time
but
uh i know what he's going to say jim
harbaugh i don't know um
you know it's funny i i you know
harbaugh's just one of the most
complicated and interesting people
in all of sports but and not that he
really says interesting things but
i believe you may know him i had the
opportunity to get together with him
about two years ago
set up by his brother-in-law tom crean
and there were there were some
complications and i it was my fault i
couldn't get up there i was in
california working on
something and uh i'm sorry that i missed
it out because i i really believe deep
down he's a fascinating guy he's just
not a particularly good college football
coach right now
yeah because that's always weird if
you're like our job
is not to have preferential treatment
like you're supposed to see it
and then say it not factor in well i do
like this guy
and you've been brutally honest about
jim harbaugh
not being a great coach or being
overrated or i don't want to
i'm paraphrasing here but you i've said
it all
how awkward would it be though like if i
said hey jim harbaugh would love to meet
you
and uh he's going to be in the area he's
going to be at the mothership and he
wants to meet with you at espn
i would do it in a second and by the way
uh yeah i'm i'm i'm in my 60s now dan
i've had a career of having awkward
meetings with people that did not like
me
uh it wouldn't be the first time so i
there there's a there's an
art of the deal so to speak not to
recreate a bestseller from from the
80s and 90s but uh i i'm always willing
to meet anyone i
i and and you guys like us we don't
dislike people personally it's just
we we say what we believe it's it's not
personal what's the most awkward
encounter you've had in this job uh
interestingly it was lane kiffin
um i don't know how much time we have
i'll tell you this quick story
i was on college game day in uh 2013
before they played i think it was
arizona and i said
if if if if usc can't win tonight uh
lane kiffin should be fired well guess
what
they didn't win and he was fired and uh
the next morning on uh a sports center
pretty much blamed me for the
firing and uh i
i said he was the miley cyrus of college
football
and i mean i got uh so two weeks later
i'm out in
the university of washington doing game
day and
i find out uh a couple hours uh the
night before that lane kiffin was going
to give his first interview so
i'm in the i walk in the meeting and
there's lane tiffin and i
i was a little bit cautious so i just
decided screw it
i'm going to walk over to him i didn't
know whether he was going to throw a
punch not that i was overly concerned
about
you know getting punched out by lane
kiffin but uh i said hello we ended up
becoming fast friends we started
corresponding he sent me a miley cyrus
uh
uh song the next day and uh it it
wait wait wait wait just wait a miley
cyrus song
yeah he i see i called him the miley
cyrus from college football coaches
so um uh and uh he uh
yeah he he showed me his personality so
i mean after that i'm really not afraid
of anyone but i've talked to people that
i've called for for their firings before
so it can be awkward
even years later um but uh yeah it does
to quote the oldest cliche in the
business come with the territory
yeah and there are times you say
something and then you have no idea why
somebody's mad at you or
somebody will say oh uh he heard what
you said and i'll be like
i spent i have three hours a day five
days a week and i've been doing this for
over 30 years chances are somebody's
going to be upset at something i said
you're jeff you're never quite sure if
they heard it or
somebody relate it to and usually when
they relay it to somebody
it's far worse than when they hear it on
their own
i i've had people come at me from 25
years ago uh
it wasn't that long ago a coach that i
wrote an article about when i was a
newspaper
uh writer and he was fired uh
he started attacking me at an event and
i'm like going i mean buddy this is
this is at least 25 years in the past
but you know to that person
and it's really a lesson these things
they never leave you uh although
you know some of them probably could use
some psychiatric counseling
of all the fan bases though what's
what's the one that
may be most sensitive or makes you a
little nervous
um well i i spent most of my life in
alabama so i would never
come after the crimson tide fans or
auburn
uh i i i have had more problems um
with michigan fans because they just
seem like they're everywhere
uh and until recently i mean i was about
two years ago i was walking down
in georgetown and the michigan fans like
came up to me and wanted to accost me
um they they they are in another world
because
dan michigan michigan st even though
they haven't they've won i think one and
a half national championships in
50 years uh they still think they're
elite
so when you criticize harbaugh until
recently when you
when you criticize harbaugh they took it
so personally they still take it
personally but
uh you know they don't bother me as much
but but they're probably the most
difficult fan base i have had to deal
with these comments aren't going to help
that
situation
the good news is i'm not traveling to
michigan yeah anytime soon
yeah no reason to go there um hey great
great to talk to you
and uh thanks for joining us as always
paul dan it's always a pleasure thank
you for having me that's paul feinbaum
espn radio host host of the paul
feinbaum show the voice of the sec